Russia has called Washington's decision
to send depleted uranium rounds to
Ukraine a criminal act the U.S has
pledged the armor-piercing tank rounds
and its latest one billion dollar
military aid package the highly dense
radioactive material is effective
against armor but its use in war has
been controversial some studies of its
use by the U.S and Iraq have linked the
rounds to increased health risks let's
go to our correspondent Julio
shapovalova who is in Moscow for us
Julia has there been any reaction from
Russia to this
well of course there's been reaction
from the Russian side mostly
highlighting some terrible environmental
and health consequences related to the
Munitions with depleted uranium Russia
strongly condemned the use of such
weapons opposing the White House
statement that the shells did not pose a
radioactive threat and Deputy foreign
minister Sergey Repco has said that the
U.S decision to transfer depleted
uranium shells to Kiev is a criminal act
as you said he cited hundreds of expert
materials published around the world
with opinions of doctors ecologists
chemists about the harm that such
weapons can pose to the environment and
he said that Washington doesn't care at
all because that particular kind of
ammunition will not be used on their
territories but on the territory of
Ukraine and he highlighted the dangers
posed by such weapons for people who are
fighting there right now and for the
generations to come and also foreign
Ministry spokeswoman Maria Zahara she
also commented on the dangers of such
weapons with examples dating back to the
Yugoslavia War by the way the Yuan also
opposed the use of shells with a
depleted uranium anywhere in the world
well can we expect Russia to change its
strategy because of this
well actually the Kremlin uh commenting
on the U.S plans to continue providing
such assistance to Ukraine said that uh
that would not affect the course of this
special military operation in Ukraine it
will continue no matter what and uh
Russian President Vladimir Putin
previously warned that Moscow would be
forced to respond to deliveries of
depleted uranium shells to Ukraine and
back in March when Britain said it would
Supply the shells the Russian president
warned that Moscow would respond and uh
Putin followed out several days later by
saying that Russia would respond by
stationing tactical nuclear weapons in
neighboring Belarus and we remember that
Putin and the Belarusian president said
in July that Russia had actually shipped
some of the weapons there
there for us in Moscow thank you